[Music]
so
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock the uk is buying up tens of
millions more vaccines and according to
the world health organization that's not
only selfish but it also means covid
won't be wiped out globally because
there aren't enough for the poorest
countries what's sensible and what's
fair plus what to do about the christmas
party should we listen to ministers
or scientists this morning we'll be
hearing from both including in a few
minutes the science minister george
freeman and
i take his hand
it's so cold to touch
not like the man and the father i miss
so much
just for dad the son of one of rugby's
finest nigel stamos smith will tell us
about the song detailing his father's
battle with alzheimer's and
oh
goodness what made that raging bull
elephant do that he charged a safari
vehicle in a south african game park
will speak to an expert on elephant
behavior dr joyce poole it's thursday
the 2nd of december
the uk seals a deal to buy more than 100
million extra covered doses including
modified doses for new strains like the
omicron variant
i'm live at a pharmacy in north london
where the pressure is on to get those
jabs into arms as quickly as possible
staying safe why the new variant could
prolong the isolation of the families of
highly vulnerable people
knowing that it's going to protect my
dad from catching whatever's out there
and just keeping him safe
it does tell you that you are doing a
good thing
the women's tennis association suspends
all tournaments in china over concerns
for the safety of the player pong shui
at the center of the trial of gillane
maxwell her defense team tried to
undermine a witness who claimed the
british socialite was involved in sex
trafficking for jeffrey epstein
the defense hopes to build up this
picture of false memories and convey the
idea to the jury of them being
unreliable witnesses
the supreme court begins the case which
will decide the future of abortion in
much of the united states
[Music]
morning everybody the government has
agreed to buy more than 100 million more
doses of covid 19 vaccine shots speeding
up the orders as it tries to curb the
spread of the new omicron variant the
deal will include access to modified
vaccines to counter new strains but it
comes as the world health organization
launches a campaign for global vaccine
parity saying that unless people in the
poorest countries are vaccinated new
variants will continue to emerge
the uk government has ordered a total of
114 million extra coronavirus vaccines
to help cover the next two years
60 million are from moderna and 54
million are from pfizer
it includes access to modified
vaccinations to combat omicron or other
emerging variants
well who's going to do all of this let's
chat to ashna she's outside a pharmacy a
chemist for us in north london this
morning and a lot of this is going to
fall to the chemist isn't it ashna good
morning
it really is it's going to be down to
those hospital hubs those community
pharmacies and also those bigger
hospitals to try and distribute all of
these vaccines you're right though the
key in all of this is the modified
vaccines as well it's all very well
accelerating the supply of it but with
these new variants and variants of
interest and variance of concern of
course the vaccine needs to adapt and
and be
sort of morphed i suppose to to be able
to tackle these variants this is exactly
what this new supplier will be doing
they've signed this contract with
moderna with pfizer and biontech as well
and this comes at mid now variance the
number of cases of this variant of
concern has gone up to 32 across england
and scotland of course it is down to
places like this to distribute those
vaccines particularly that booster
program that huge booster campaign down
to places like this to get those jabs
into arms at the moment it's targeted at
the 40
population who are aged 40 and over but
there is the ambition that by january by
the end of january all adults over 18
are going to end up getting these jabs
so they've got a huge job ahead because
you've got to balance up you know the
speed at which this uh variant is
spreading but also whether they can keep
up with the pace of it and whether it's
going to reach its peak by the point
that we're all vaccinated against it and
given that extra layer of protection so
a lot to watch but it is
good news in the eyes of many this
contract has been signed but when you
speak to the world health organization
a big big um sort of red flag for them
is surrounding vaccine equity hey
astronomer thanks so much indeed thanks
a lot
uh the new omicron variant is already
having a major impact in south africa
where the number of new covet 19 cases
is surging from a weekly average of
around 300 new cases a day to a thousand
last week to more than 8 000 cases
reported yesterday new cases have almost
doubled in 24 hours more than 8500
infections recorded yesterday up from
nearly 4 400 the day before the new
strain accounted for three quarters of
the virus genome sequence last month
according to south africa's national
institute for communicable diseases
scientists believe they've found why the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine has in a few
very rare cases caused blood clots
researchers in cardiff and the u.s have
discovered a chain reaction after
protein from the blood mixes with the
vaccine the vaccine was withdrawn from
some age groups in the uk and elsewhere
but astrazeneca says it has saved more
than a million lives worldwide
joining us now is the science minister
george freeman mr freeman good to talk
to you this morning thank you for
joining us we were promised a plan by
your colleagues uh rowlight plan uh
earlier on this week where's the plan
morning kay yeah good to join you um
today we've got all of the global fire
pharma leaders here in london to
announce another half a billion pound
package into uk life science and as your
report highlights this pandemic isn't
over and the uk is leading in both the
science of defeating this virus and in
the rollout package for vaccines here in
the uk we've procured another 114
million doses so we've got the doses
here for patients over the next few
months and we're in a global race to
make sure we defeat this pandemic and
i'm here today to talk about how uk
science is right on the front line of
that we're working across government to
lead the global fight to defeat the
virus
and an answer to my question
yeah so we're working right now across
government on how we both uh accelerate
the rollout internationally of vaccines
the truth is we're not safe until the
world is safe and the uk has led that
charge we've invested more per capita
than any other nation we're huge
supporters of kovacs and at the g7
summit uh this summer we led the charge
on how globally we support international
rollout here in the uk our vaccine
rollout program is setting the benchmark
and that's why we're able this year to
not impose
the very tough uh quite draconian
regulations we had to last year
in a way that other countries are so
this is uk science leadership and nhs
leadership and the vaccine rollout
program
leading
here in the uk in terms of science but
also allowing our citizens to enjoy
fewer restrictions than in other
countries
on monday we were promised to plan it's
thursday we haven't got a plan people
don't know when they can have their
boosters where's the plan
the nhs i'll
have a plan it's being rolled out and
people can apply now i've just had my
text last night my booster appointment
has been offered for next week and
people across my constituency and around
the country are able now to get their
boosters and i would having had covered
myself three weeks ago this is not a
nice disease i was double jabbed went
down for a week and i would encourage
everybody
contact your gp get on the app book your
booster jab uh the nhs is
uh there we're rolling it out we've
procured the vaccines and we're leading
the world in that rollout so this is
good news um i just encourage everyone
to make sure we get there
yeah in your 20s and 30s when can you go
onto the app to book your job
so if you contact your gp there are
slight differences around the country
but at the moment we're the first
country to get to this point we've got
80 percent of the whole country double
jabbed
and
we've got
nearly
90 percent of the whole country first
jabbed and we're now rolling it out fast
now some gp practices are rolling
slightly quicker than others uh and
that's what you'd expect but
uh if people contact their gp now and go
on the app they can book uh to get their
um their boosted jab or their second job
that's not true minister you can't get
your booster at the moment if you're in
your 20s the question is we were told
earlier in the week that we wouldn't
there's a plan i'm just asking you where
the plan is and when people in their 20s
and 30s can book their booster
well the nhs are leading on that role
and i haven't got on my fingertips today
exactly which gp practices are making it
available today but we are accelerating
that rollout and it is key
and we will we are uh putting that in
place so that the next generation uh the
next age cohort can get uh their booster
jab as quickly as possible but uh the
nhs has got uh to put that alongside
clearing the back club of cancer cases
and all of the other issues that the
pandemic has caused i think the public
understand that
we have to do everything we can we are
the nhs is flat out i was in
constituency surgeries in my patch last
week and the booster rollout and the jab
program is working i'm not getting a lot
of complaints from people saying the uk
is behind on its vaccination program of
course we all need to move fast and we
are and the nhs is doing that that's why
we've put more money in we only have a
limited minister we only have a limited
amount of time the answer is you don't
know the answer let me let me put this
to you south africa averaging 300 cases
no you don't the answer if you're only
20.
if you're in your 20s you don't know
when you can have the jab just just
admit to that because that's that is
fundamentally the case isn't it
the case is that the nhs is rolling out
the vaccine program and
if you contact your gp
and book it you will get your your your
jab it's not true it's just not true
it's just not true minister um south
africa um averaging 300 cases a day that
has led to eight and a half thousand
cases yesterday how concerned are we
yeah well as the prime minister and the
health secretary charter secretary have
set out we are concerned that's why
we've put in place
uh some pretty important reasonable
measures to make sure that red list
countries have to test before they come
we're trying to make sure that the
global economy can carry on working
while minimizing the risk i think that's
the key we in those countries where
the new variant is surging we need to be
quite tough and make sure that people
aren't bringing it in contain it
and then when it's here make sure that
we're containing it here in the uk we
did it before we've learned a huge
amount in the last year and we'll do it
again and today
we've got all the global leaders in the
vaccine industry here because the uk is
leading the charge globally this is a
pandemic it isn't over yet and the uk is
leading in making sure that we both
tackle the virus
and make sure that we're leading in the
rollout program
given that how many doses have we
delivered to kovacs we promised 100
million didn't we
yeah the problem with kovacs actually
has been and i set a up a commission
last year before coming back into
government that the global manufacturing
supply chains for example india a major
manufacturer of vaccines around the
world india was hit really hard by the
pandemic and one of the things we set
out in our g7 summit in the summer which
is partly what we're picking up today is
to make sure that we've got those global
supply chains so britain has put the
funding in we've procured the vaccines
the key is getting the roll out
internationally into some of those
hard-to-reach countries in africa in the
some of the pacific island states and
that is a global challenge that's why
we're one of the biggest contributors to
kovacs who are doing a brilliant job
we've put the vaccines in we've got to
make sure that we support them in
rolling them out internationally because
as i say we're not safe the global
economy isn't safe until we've defeated
this pandemic across the whole world
we promised 100 million how many have we
delivered
we've we've supported that 100 million
they're in the pipeline that isn't the
issue okay the issue is getting them out
around the country which is why we're
focusing today on
how many of we've delivered
i'm sorry i'm sorry how many have we
delivered of the 100 million that we
promised you mean have we
have we delivered to kovacs
yes
yeah we we're on schedule i haven't got
that number at my fingertips now but we
are
on schedule the issue isn't lack of you
yeah that but that isn't what's holding
up the global rollout program okay
what's holding it up as i say is that
international supply chain issue around
the world and nobody is saying we're not
getting them
enough because the uk hasn't supported
so why why are we taking so many more um
uh vaccines uh here in the uk then tens
of millions more of what we've ordered
shouldn't we given that we're not safe
until everyone's safe shouldn't we be
diverting those two third world
countries
so it's a balance okay i mean we've got
another variant i think the british
public would expect us to make sure that
we've made sure to your earlier point in
this interview that we're providing the
supply here in the uk and that's why
we've just procured another 114 million
doses precisely to make sure we can
deliver that roll out here in the uk as
well this is a balance we've got to make
sure that our citizens are safe
and that the global vaccine roll out
through kovacs is supported
and that is what we're committed to
doing and it's why today we've got as
part of that g7 follow-up all the global
leaders in vaccine science here in the
uk
number two three
on times okay um right we've got it
that's right okay because it's an
international challenge go on because we
only have a short period of time as you
know minister it's always difficult when
you're not with me because obviously
i'm interrupting you so forgive me for
that uh given that you say that we need
more vaccines in the uk are we going to
inoculate five to 11 year olds they are
in italy and they are in israel
well we're looking at that the science
on that and the balance of roll rollout
patrick valance as our chief scientist
and chris whittie are advising on that
and it's their advice that guides us the
urgent priority now as you highlighted
earlier is to make sure that we roll out
the jab program through the population
and with christmas coming we want to
make sure that as many people as
possible are double jabbed i think in
due course we would like to make sure
that
all of those who are vulnerable have the
right level of protection the data at
the moment suggests that young children
are much much less
vulnerable but as and when that data
changes we're guided by the science and
we stand ready it's partly why we've
procured the vaccines to make sure that
we can deliver what our citizens and
patients need
okay we are out of town i just want to
ask you one final question before i let
you go though minister if you will
indulge me apparently emmanuel macron
has uh said it's very sad to see a great
country with which we could do so much
led by a clown
uh talking about boris johnson what
would you say in response
well i think we're into pantomime season
aren't we and there's a french election
coming it's a pretty unhelpful word of
course the prime minister's in the clown
he's the elected prime minister of this
country with a very big mandate leading
this country through the pandemic the
truth is we are looking to work very
closely with france on the border issue
on tackling
the problem of european migration at
source that's why we're investing in
trying to stabilize countries so that
people aren't coming here and with
france we need to make sure that people
in fro in france aren't being supplied
with boats and being pushed out into the
channel the home secretary is working
closely with french counterparts on it
and the prime minister and the uk
government is looking for a sensible
conversation with france about it so
i'm confident that actually anglo-french
relations are rather better than that
quote suggests
are you planning a lovely christmas
i think all of us are hoping that this
christmas we'll be able to enjoy
more freedom than we did last christmas
um
but uh you know we're in this pandemic
and hopefully this new variant isn't
going to sweep through
the country and we won't have to put in
place those restrictions last year and
the vaccine program is our best defense
against that um so i think everyone
as the prime minister said should be
able to plan for christmas but we're
going to have to be sensible and that's
why we've upped the guidance
masks on public transport
masks in shops but we also want people
to be able to go to
clubs and to pubs and be able to have a
drink
and eat which you can't do if you're
wearing a mask it's common sense really
i think the british public understand
that the more we can prevent the
transmission of the virus the more we'll
be able to enjoy the freedoms we all
cherish and
to me wearing a mask on a tube in winter
weather particularly isn't onerous and i
think if we wear masks in shops and on
public transport we've got a higher
chance of being able to enjoy those
freedoms we all cherish
okay good to talk to you minister thank
you so much for taking the time much
appreciated
thank you thank you
well the new omicron variant of covid19
could have far more wide-ranging
consequences for some people than the
need to wear a mask or miss a christmas
party for families of the most
vulnerable people it could mean more
time in isolation and for some that has
already meant staying behind closed
doors for more than a year as emma
birchley reports
for 12 long months the pretties have
been stuck at home
no leaving for school or
lunch is work
[Music]
it's a choice they made together after
greg was diagnosed with a brain tumor in
lockdown last november i had to tell joe
over the phone and struggled to get get
the words out first few days when i was
in hospital all sorts of things are
going through your mind you know how
long have i got you know is this is it
terminal am i going to see the kids grow
up high-dose chemotherapy and a stem
cell transplant stripped his immune
system and doctors suggested they shield
even when it was no longer government
advice
it is the hardest thing i've ever had to
do in my life obviously we're missing
our friends and family but more
it is the children missing school and
their friends
amelia is 16 her brother is just 13.
knowing that it's going to protect my
dad from catching whatever's out there
and just keeping him safe
it does tell you that you are doing a
good thing it may not seem it
from other people because they're like
they're stuck in a house they can't go
out or socialize or anything but knowing
that you're protecting your dad from
obviously catching anything it's really
really good instead of moping the
children have fundraised for brain tumor
research making more than 13 000 pounds
so far
emilia choreographed 20 requested dances
in 20 days
and wheels has worn a mini track in the
lawn running a mile a day
up to four miles daily in a festive
outfit until christmas
it makes me wanna like make sure
everyone in the world knows about how
bad brain tumors are
and like to me it helps me with my rugby
so i'm like and it's making me more
determined to get in back on the pitch
being stuck in another day another bit
of exercise to build my strength back up
again from all the chemo
next month once greg's immune system is
back in action they'll finally leave the
house after another christmas on their
own but will still need to be cautious i
feel that everyone should have the kovid
jab and wear masks adhere to the rules
and
just keep everyone needs to keep every
other person safe greg is currently in
remission for the family it makes the
sacrifice of the past year or worth it
but they can't wait to be free
emma birchley sky news stains
well let's look at some of the stories
on the front pages of the newspapers for
you today this is what they look like
the health secretary encouraging people
to take cover tests
before attending christmas party the
metro proclaims let it flow let it flow
let it flow see what they did there
lateral flows uh the mirror has more
details of what it says went on at a
downing street christmas party
reportedly held at the height of
lockdown last year
the eye highlights the government's
purchase of 114 million pfizer and
moderna booster vaccine doses enough to
see the uk through 2023.
according to the guardian ministers are
paving the way to allowing gps to stop
monitoring patients with non-covered
underlying conditions in order to
concentrate on the booster effort
finally the time says france's president
macron privately branded boris johnson a
clown and a knucklehead and says france
papers regard anglo-french relations as
the worst
since waterloo i did put that to the
minister a few moments ago and he said
it's pantomime season they would say
that wouldn't they and they need to do
more to stop people coming across the
channel risking their lives after half
past seven going to be discussing the
booster rollout with the chief exec of
the association for independent multiple
pharmacies a lot of the heavy lifting
falling to pharmacies and shortly after
that talking about the global
vaccination rollout with the chief exec
of the world health organization
foundation
we'll also speak to researcher dr joyce
poole about why she believes that bull
elephant charged a safari vehicle
in south africa
[Music]
everything wrong about that now a 15
year old boy has been charged with
murder and terrorism over a school
shooting in michigan that left four
students dead police say ethan crumbly
had recorded a video the night before
the shooting where he threatened
violence against the school the
prosecutor is also considering charges
against his parents after they attended
a school meeting hours before the
shooting
the actor alec baldwin has said he did
not pull the trigger of the gun that
killed the cinematographer helena
hutchins on a film set back in october
he made the claim in an interview with
abc to be aired in the u.s this evening
investigators in new mexico are looking
into how live bullets got onto the set
but no criminal charges have as yet been
filed
police are looking for a suspect after
an officer was sprayed in the face with
an unknown substance while on duty at
westminster the suspect ran off after
the attack which happened at around
eight o'clock last night the officer did
not need hospital treatment
the supreme court's conservative
majority has signaled a willingness to
curtail abortion rights in the united
states and possibly overturn the 1973
roe v wade ruling that legalized
terminations the supreme court justices
indicated they will uphold a restrictive
republican-backed mississippi law that
would outlaw the procedure after 15
weeks of pregnancy the court is
preparing to rule in the southern states
appeal to revive its ban after it was
blocked by lower courts a ruling is
expected by the end of next summer
the women's tennis association has
suspended all tournaments in china over
concerns for the safety of the player
feng shui the chinese star wasn't seen
in public for three weeks after she
accused a senior government official of
sexual assault the wta says despite
repeated requests it's not been able to
talk to her directly billie jean king
the american tennis great and the
founder of the wta is among those who've
applauded the announcement she's tweeted
i applaud steve simon and the wta
leadership for taking a strong stand on
defending human rights in china and
around the world the wta is on the right
side of history in supporting our
players this is another reason why
women's tennis is the leader in women's
sports
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's back to being chilly again
overnight frost some snow mainly on
northern hills quite frosty at the
moment with wintry showers over northern
eastern and south western britain
bringing some icy stretches
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and some of the other stories that have
caught our eye in the papers for you
this morning this is what the team have
put together for you here we go
do you remember that raid one of the
most audacious heists of all time and it
could be brought to life uh like never
before at the hatton garden vault
plundered by a gang of aging burglars
remember becomes a museum piece
apparently the museum of london are
putting the final touches to plans to
relocate the strong room to smithfield
market so you can get a sense of the
robbery itself do you remember that it
was over a bank holiday weekend wasn't
it and they drilled through almost got
away with it but
they're now in prison because they just
couldn't keep their mouth shut no on a
wing and a hair the daily mail shows off
a beautiful formation of starlings at
reed beds nature reserve in suffolk can
you see
there you go there's his bottom
and there's his ear very good isn't it
they're preparing to roost apparently
let's have a look at the telegraph
a pinch me moment
as entertainer tommy steele becomes a
sir for his contributions to charity and
music i was hoping we'd be able to play
some music from him this morning but i
don't think we can which is a shame
flashbang wallop i think was probably
one of my favorite when i was a little
girl he's um 84 and he was knighted by
the princess royal lovely
now we've got more extraordinary shots
for you this morning of the volcano on
the spanish island of la palma this is
what it's doing today she really has not
had enough yet there you go these are
drone pictures and show you another one
of the physios that's going from the top
of the volcano the mouth of the volcano
right down to the sea uh the eruption
shows no signs of stopping after more
than 10 weeks that fresh river of lava
flowing seemingly endlessly and is
threatening to engulf a church that so
far survived the eruption we were
speaking to volcanologists who were
telling us it's really impressive isn't
it that they think that it will continue
on until at least
christmas
which is really not very far away now is
it uh coming up going to be discussing
the booster row light with the chief
exec of the association for independent
multiple pharmacies
that to come
[Music]
government has denied that the
vaccination programme is in confusion
with those in their 20s and 30s unable
to book a vaccination slot short while
ago i asked the science minister george
freeman
when booster programme would be fully up
and running this is what he said
we are accelerating that rollout and it
is key uh and we will we are putting
that in place so that the next
generation uh the next stage cohort can
get uh their booster jab as quickly as
possible but uh the nhs has got uh to
put that alongside clearing the back
club of cancer cases and all of the
other issues that the pandemic has
caused i think the public understand
that
we have to do everything we can we are
the nhs is flat out i was in
constituency surgeries in my patch last
week and the booster rollout and the jab
program is working i'm not getting a lot
of complaints from people saying the uk
is behind on its vaccination program of
course we all need to move fast and we
are and the nhs is doing that that's why
we've put more money in to support that
program
butler's confusion and the minister i
think tomorrow good morning was confused
good morning yes george freeman there
saying that we know the government has
said that all adults will be offered a
booster jab by the end of january that's
going to be a pretty quick turnaround
more than half a million a day but he
said that people in their 20s should
contact their gp surgeries the firm
message from the government is you
should wait until they send you a text
message george freeman said that he had
got a text message about his booster
next week people are being told that
they will go down the age range so
currently if you're over 40 you should
be able to get a text message to book in
your booster but people in their 30s 20s
over 18s will need to wait until later
in december to hear when your boost is
going to be we've heard that these
websites where people are trying to book
them are are crashing and that's because
the government's messages you should
wait to be told when it is when it is
going to be
and what are the public supposed to
think when even the minister who's
representing the government this morning
doesn't know the rules well i think
there's a lot of confusion because the
nhs are supposed to be doing a plan for
how they're going to roll these out and
that hasn't actually been published yet
because we know that gps are quite
concerned about how they are going to
find the capacity to do vaccines they're
going to get money from the government
for the vaccines but what do they stop
doing in order to free up capacity the
government wants to make more use of
pharmacies for example but they'll need
more volunteers so you need a whole plan
behind this and we're still waiting to
hear about that the big news today
though is that the government has done a
deal with pfizer to get
114 million more doses over the next two
years so that raises the possibility of
a fourth dose fifth dose even beyond
that and they'll be able to be modified
so if omicron or other variants need
changes to the vaccine that will be
possible but of course raises questions
about how many are going to go to
developing countries indeed so we asked
him that as well didn't we tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock looking forward to
it thank you
1500 community pharmacies are to play an
essential role as tomorrow was saying in
the rollout of booster jobs if the
program is to be completed by the end of
january joining us now is laila hambeck
the chief exec of the association of
independent multiple pharmacies hello to
you good morning thank you for joining
us a lot of heavy lifting falling to
your members
oh yes um of course
well we have been campaigning for this
since the the beginning of this year and
it's good to see that pharmacists are
being involved
in this program throughout the pandemic
pharmacists have kept the doors open
looking after patients and developed and
providing that sort of accessibility
for patient care so
it's the right thing to do to get
pharmacies involved
yeah but how difficult will it be to and
will they be able to will your members
be able to cope with the number of
people that are going to need
vaccinations given that um doctor
surgeries won't be able to do what they
did previously in a lot of these hubs
vaccine hubs
are not there like they were earlier in
the year
yeah so
at the moment we've got a thousand four
hundred pharmacies that have been
providing the corporate vaccination
service and between them they have jobs
about 15 million people so that is a
great number and we know that community
pharmacy can achieve this um but we do
need the support from the government in
terms of like making sure that we
prioritize things so
getting rid of red tape and making sure
that we are properly funded and that the
vaccine availability is there is
obviously a key factor for us
but we are willing we are ready
but we do need that support in order to
move forward and how are your members
coping with the pressure
um there are pressures particularly
during winter and
you know and we've been under pressure
the whole throughout the the pandemic in
that we've kept our doors open and
seeing patients um however um it's
important that we prioritize we can only
do this if priorities are made and the
support for government is received in
that um you know we're making sure that
we put aside things that we no longer
need to do for this period of time and
we focus on on on the on the corporate
vaccination service again we also do flu
vaccination as well so we break broken
records on that as well
so we are willing but the support is
required for us to be able to
to manage this
what support are we talking about
we're talking about prioritization
making sure that there's you know we're
cutting the red tape we are talking
about making sure that we've got the
right funding to enable us to carry on
with our business as usual as well
because that's not that's not going to
go away we have to make sure that we
look after our patients
and also we have to make sure that we
have relevant workforce in place uh in
order uh to deliver this and
for that um you know that's
kind of the support that we require from
the government and making sure that the
systems work for example the national
booking system the vaccine supply all of
that
you know we don't want to be in a
situation where you're chasing things up
that require that consume a lot of time
and people watching this morning can
they just pop down to their local
chemist and say put a booster in my arm
people people need to go through the
national booking system so um and the
national working system has has been in
place for for some time and if they have
any questions they can contact the
11119 number
in order to ask questions but they can
also ask their pharmacy teams in terms
of like what needs to happen and the
pharmacy teams will be able to uh
support them and guide them in the right
direction
okay it's good to talk to you thanks so
much indeed for explaining that to us
thank you thank you
so our wonderful chemist pharmacists are
willing and ready but they do need the
support let's turn our two efforts to
roll out the vaccine on a global scale
should we and joining us is anil sonny
here chief exec of the world health
organization foundation hello t thank
you so much for joining us on the
programme this morning uh what more does
the developed world need to do to help
those less fortunate
well thank you for having me
the the developed world needs to follow
through on its pledges to donate doses
and to ensure that the governments of
low-income countries have support doses
funding technical support to roll out
vaccines currently less than five
percent of the population of low-income
countries has been vaccinated vaccine
inequity is morally unjust it's also
epidemiologically and economically
self-defeating so it's in all of our
interest to ensure that everyone is
vaccinated
isn't that what kovacs is for
exactly kovacs is delivering vaccines
around the world in fact kovacs has
contracts for 3.7 billion vaccines only
500 million have been delivered wealthy
countries have promised to donate 1.4
billion doses but less than 200 million
have been delivered we want to create
the ability for everyone to use their
voice and their wallet to contribute uh
people-powered vaccines can be an
important motivator to elected
representatives the who foundation
created the campaign go give one go give
one.org where you can give 4 quid and
buy a vaccine for someone else and show
that you are willing to do what you want
your government to do which is to follow
through on its commitments to donate
vaccines through kovacs
so i i put this to the government
minister this morning i don't know if
you heard him or not but he was
basically saying there was a big fire as
we know
in india
earlier on in the year and as a result
there aren't enough vaccines to go
around at the moment
i don't believe that's true
there are more than 800 million excess
doses in high income countries across
the g7 including the uk that is a lot of
doses that can be distributed are there
enough doses to vaccinate everyone in
the world not necessarily but there are
enough doses to vaccinate just as many
people in low-income countries as in
high-income countries we have the
vaccines now what we need to do is
follow through in our promise to deliver
them and make sure that people have
access
how disappointed are you with the
british government
i am
proud as someone who spent 20 years
working on hiv aids that in such a short
period of time in this pandemic we've
developed vaccines and delivered them to
more than three and a half billion
people i am incredibly disappointed in
everyone any government and any leader
who has facilitated the inequity such
that people who are in high income
countries including myself and my family
have access we are privileged we are
protected i am grateful for that the
fact that my family and relatives and
other parts of the world don't have
access that's a tragedy and we should
all be held accountable for that
including the british government
indeed any government that can do more
that isn't
okay one in two people in high income
countries i believe have been vaccinated
we talk about low-income countries it
falls to one in 13 people
what impact is that vaccine inequality
actually having in real terms
it breeds variance it also causes
massive economic damage it's in our
interest our self-interest to ensure
that everyone is vaccinated the world is
a petri dish when you have a population
that's well vaccinated but another
population that's not it's in that
population of people that is not well
vaccinated that you have variants that's
where they emerge and variance risk
reducing the efficacy of the existing
vaccine and also it has massive economic
damage trillions of dollars is what it's
going to cost high-income countries the
uk europe the united states because
low-income countries don't have high
vaccine coverage rates
the world health organization had set a
target of 70
of the the world the globe to be
vaccinated by the middle of next year is
that still within reach
if we act we're certainly not on track
today the interim target was to reach 40
of the world by the end of 2021 it's
december 2nd that's days weeks away we
have to do much more much more quickly
in order to keep that 70 target alive
and real
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for taking the time
much appreciated thank you thank you
the defense in the trial of gillane
maxwell has been trying to cast doubt on
the allegations of one of the key
witnesses against her who claimed that
she was sexually exploited when she was
just 14. ms maxwell's brother kevin was
in court and spoke afterwards to
reporters complaining about the
condition of her detention ius
correspondent martha kelner has this
report which contains flash photography
their sister is in the dock and gelane
maxwell's siblings are suddenly in the
spotlight they heard graphic details in
court of her alleged sex trafficking of
teenage girls but for kevin maxwell it's
been a welcome reunion
personally it was a
tremendous tremendous sense of relief
to be close to her
to be able to actually see her in the
flesh
even to be able to speak with her that's
the first time that i've spoken to her
personally
in over
500 days
since her pre-trial detention started
and
to see her
looking
pretty well
and notwithstanding the conditions
of detention
which are now the subject
of a formal complaint to the united
nations
the grueling testimony in new york
continued jane a pseudonym claims
maxwell and jeffrey epstein abused her
from the age of 14 but maxwell's lawyer
highlighted inconsistencies
between what jane said on the stand and
her evidence to fbi investigators in
2019
defender laura meninger said you came up
with that memory in the last two years
jane responded i don't believe i came up
with a memory no
pressed on that jane said memory is not
linear
by calling upon apparent inconsistencies
in the accounts given by the alleged
victims testifying here the defense
hopes to build up this picture of false
memories and convey the idea to the jury
of them being unreliable witnesses
with more accusers waiting to testify
maxwell's family are bracing themselves
to hear further damaging accounts of her
life and alleged crimes martha calnet
sky news new york
of course we will continue to cover that
trial for you throughout a more on uh
covid uh vaccination program coming up
in the next hour here on the program
labour will be with us here in the
studio meantime let me show you this
fossils found in chile are from a
strange looking dog size dinosaur
species apparently but unlike man's best
friend wagging its tail meant
trouble
the new species described in a study in
the journal nature has something never
seen before on any animal seven pairs of
blades
laid out sideways on its tail and used
as a unique slashing
weapon
the newly identified armored dinosaur
inhabited the patagonian region of chile
not necessarily a four-legged friend
i wonder if it was a her before you've
got to hope so haven't you
uh coming up
also not man's best friend we're going
to be speaking to dr joyce poole about
why she believes this elephant charged a
safari vehicle in south africa
[Music]
now a group of trainee game rangers in
south africa have had a lucky escape
after their game vehicle was charged by
an elephant this is what happened
why on earth did that happen dr joyce
poole is an elephant behavior
analyst and is with us hello to you
doctor um there's all sorts of things
wrong with that what's your
interpretation
well uh
i mean must may this this elephant was
in must which is a period of heightened
sexual and aggressive activity that
males go go through uh typically once a
year
but it's it's it's not that common that
that males uh will hit the car like that
in ambassador where i've worked for and
i've studied elephants for over 45 years
uh there has been only one incident and
it has the highest density of musk males
on the continent and that particular
case was when some tourists got between
two fighting males
um in this case it's it's hard to say
without knowing the full context what
happened
what i saw was that the vehicle was
moving in the full video the vehicle was
moving um the elephants ahead a family
group were agitated and then the must
male came you know out from the side
as their vehicle was turning toward the
must male
um
you know
it's an open vehicle there's uh an
outrigger with uh with a spotter sitting
on the front
elephants don't like to see silhouettes
of people um
you know in a way possibly it's asking
for
for trouble
yeah i mean you just an elephant in must
you stay well away from them they're
properly grumpy aren't they um they all
then got out of the vehicle
we can see why they did but but in more
danger once you're on foot i'm guessing
yes i mean uh you know it's not
advisable to just jump out of the
vehicle but i think in that case where
they had another vehicle behind that was
the safest thing to to do
um what do you do if you come across an
elephant in most
well i studied them i you know i did i
actually discovered mustang african
elephants and i studied them for many
many years uh so i just um i i stop the
car i turn off the engine um i keep my
distance and then you know see how see
what that you know each individual is
different so
um i'm i'm actually a little surprised
there are only 135 elephants at in
salati game reserve
um apparently according to what's online
and so i'm surprised those elephants
aren't more relaxed with people
um you know it's it's had tours there
for for quite a number of years uh so
it's surprising that they're so agitated
and they do tend to give you a warning
don't they before they're charged they
generally don't just charge
yes and i don't know what happened
before that video was filmed you know
had they seen him already um in which
case i certainly wouldn't have driven up
gotten closer to the females with a
must-mail on my left i would have held
back and let the elephants come to me
yeah i think a lesson for quite a few
people in that video it's good to talk
to you doctor thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it thank you thank
you
thank you
elephants are very calm animals
generally if you are lucky enough to go
on safari and as you were hearing there
from the doctor um if the engine gets
switched off they will roam around the
vehicle they see it as neutral and
they're not going to hurt but if there's
an elephant in most you give it a very
wide berth um coming up in just a few
moments time we're talking about the
rollout program for boosters here in the
uk
uh what's it looking like who can
qualify who can't and when it would
appear
that um the minister didn't know we'll
have more on that in just a few moments
time with that tamara here and labour
with us as well please stay tuned
[Music]
you